mieux existe qu aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire entre
pauvres imbéciles
[Musique]
où
la meilleure preuve de l'existence de
dieu
c'est l'acte et tourmenté par l'absence
de dieu
[Musique]
dieu n'existe que parce que nous pensons
à lui et parce que nous l'aimons et si
aucun homme sur terre il ne pensait plus
à dieu et les mets plus dieu on peut se
demander ce que deviendrait dieu ne peut
pas parler de dieu on ne peut rien dire
de dieu on peut peut-être faire de la
fiction sur dieu c'est tout ce qu'on
peut faire parce que dieu est
entièrement hors de notre atteinte par
ma bouche il vous demande quand est ce
que vous avez voulu lâcher les baskets
de dieu
évidemment n'est ni dans l'espace ni
d'antan il est antérieure à l'espace il
est antérieure au temps et en ce sens il
n'existe pas puisqu'il est qu'il est
depuis toujours et il sera pour toujours
croyez vous en dieu j'espère qu'il y a
autre chose que ce monde et vous savez
pour commencer tout de suite par une
citation quand c'est simplement qu'il
disait ma foi et la forme de mon
espérance
je ne sais pas c'est à dire que je ne
sais pas s'il ya quelque chose après la
mort mais franchement je le souhaite je
le souhaite parce que je crois que ce
serait trop triste
vous savez j'ai souvent répéter cette
formule je crois que c'est une formule
juifs seule une formule de rabat ce
qu'il y a plus important c'est dieu
qu'il existe ou n'existe
[Musique]